[Music]
Elijah has changed over the years he's
given up we keep him heavily sedated but
there is a reason for that
it's to spot further you won't be lonely
anymore we have two new friends
[Music]
the three of you think you have
extraordinary gifts like something out
of a comic book I've developed an
effective treatment for this disorder
the light will force a different
identity to take stuff away from the
controls so you're not gonna shake my
hand and let me walk out of here good
for you what do you want I am here to
see if tales of the extraordinary be are
true may I meet the Beast
I need your abilities to get us all out
of here and show the world we exist that
sounds like the bad guys teaming up do
you believe you are an avenging angel
I'm within just
I have to get out of here before he gets
out they are contained they always
underestimate the master
it has become David I found someone will
require your full attention
you shouldn't be hiding in the shadows
you might want to try and stop us
a lot of people are going to die now
we'd like a PB and J sandwich finally
all of us together for the world to see
what we are capable of you need to get
out of here
what have you done alight
you